day 30 the general election campaign and
I'm at this address a crucial address
coming in British political history it's
where Margaret Thatcher was first
adopted as parliamentary candidate for
finchley and from when she became prime
minister there's the building's for
Churchill house now here's what's really
interesting about today GDP day in this
key swing think now officially changed
about what's really interesting is that
the GDP numbers have gone down a bit
from not point six the final quarter
last year to normal three percent and
that's the slowdown in catches day the
Conservatives were about economic
revolution right now tobacco economic
management which is why this number I'd
be a little bit difficult for them it
stands in contrast to the extraordinary
jobs numbers and gives like labor away
the economy the central plank with David
Cameron's pitch to get back to number 10
this not the number they would have
chosen and in this swing seat things
very very tight